ok trug und ob hey was geht ab herzlich
willkommen beim live view leute ich hab
natürlich gibt's natürlich muss gebiet
ich hoffe natürlich geht's gut und zwar
steht heute war dann etwas ernstes thema
an dass ich auch eigentlich schon
möglich länger machen wollte nur
irgendwie konnte ich nicht machen weil
ich nicht die mittel zu verfügung hatte
die ich dafür brauche und zwar kam
ungefähr vor zwei wochen in mein video
oder ist es glaube ich nicht mal zwei
wochen her da haben wir halt chinesische
süßigkeiten getestet und zwar an pop
kommentar testet mal sachen die schon
abgelaufen sind oder der 438 likes fand
ich war ein guter kommentar weil es
einfach ein thema ist was mich selber
schon öfter mal beschäftigt hat und
wirklich gedacht habe da kannst du
einfach mal die you tube reichweite
jetzt nutzen weil ich mir ganz sicher
bin vor allem weil auch viele jüngere
dabei sind und wie ein pariser
konsumgesellschaft aufwachsen dass man
halt denkt ihr kommt nehme ich mir davon
auch was und davor noch war es gibt ja
genug also das finde ich wirklich krass
vor allem wenn man dann mal mit seinen
großeltern so über so was redet oder
halt merkt das ist bei denen er ganz
anders ist wenn man jetzt kommt so vor
50 jahren vor allem zweiten weltkrieg
oder so war es ja so dass lebensmittel
knapp waren und dass man dadurch als
junger mensch gelernt hat etwas zu
schätzen und nicht sofort wegzuschmeißen
wenn es halt jetzt zum beispiel
abgelaufen ist oder wenn es offen ist
und man noch eine packung unterliegen
hat wie alt frisch ist wisst ihr was ich
meine und ich habe mir gedacht vor allem
jetzt weil ich selber eine eigene
wohnung gezogen bin und ich ganz genau
weiß dass wir auch relativ oft schon
gesagt haben okay wir haben jetzt hier
die wurst die müsste vielleicht nicht
mehr ganz gut sein oder wir denken die
sich mir ganz gut schmeißen wir die
beste weg bevor die schlecht ist da will
ich mich auch gar nicht rausreden oder
so das machen sicherlich eigentlich alle
jüngere menschen nur ob das richtig ist
denke ich nicht nur dann gibt es ein
leider diese sorte von menschen die
alles mögliche wegschmeißen was nicht
mehr halt nichts gut ist oder eventuell
abgelaufen sein könnte und deswegen habe
ich mir gedacht komm du wartest einfach
mal bist du genug lebensmittel zur
verfügung hast der dich schon abgelaufen
sind und probiert sie zusammen mit euch
und ich bin mir sicher habt ihr einmal
eine million schokolade ich habe viel
käse ich habe hier ein vanille joghurt
ich habe eine dose cola
ich habe einmal
lario ich habe noch eine schokolade die
sich wirklich schon ziemlich zerbröseln
anfühlt die ware bis zum 17 6 2010 teilt
bar offiziell wir haben ihnen bb von dem
ich gar nicht weiß ob er unbedingt schon
abgelaufen ist allerdings liegt ja schon
bestimmt jetzt drei monaten im
kühlschrank deswegen gehe ich mal davon
aus auch wenn ich nicht weiß wie lange
sich die teile halten und wir haben ja
noch eine milch die habe ich auch meine
ich ganz ausgetrunken hier steht bis zum
15 dritter ist die haltbar also genauer
bis heute und das ganze gilt natürlich
immer für ungeöffnete sachen das heißt
hätten wir das jetzt ungeöffnet dastehen
lassen bis zum 15
wer ist garantiert dass das ganze noch
halb weiß bis heute wenn irgendwas für
den ganzen sachen schlecht ist dann
jetzt zu 100 prozent die milch sein
wobei ich denke die kann man auch noch
trinken wovon ich weiß das ist glaube
ich ganz viele falsch verstehen ist wenn
wir hinten zum beispiel draufsteht
mindestens haltbar bis dritter dritter
das heißt nicht dass es dann am vierten
2018 schlecht ist und man das
wegschmeißen muss das heißt nur das ist
bis zum dritten drittel mindestens
haltbar ist es könnte auch noch sein
dass dieser käse noch im sommer heißt
bei milchprodukten natürlich immer ein
bisschen kritisch ist schöne grüße auch
an meine mutter die mich da auch mal
dran erinnert ja man lernt halt sachen
dazu ist schlimm und ich würde sagen
jetzt haben wir wieder lange genug
gelabert wir starten jetzt einfach mal
mit den sachen und ich würde sagen wir
fangen einfach mal gesagt schokolade an
das hier ist dass die schokolade die
sogar bis zum 14 dritter 2018 halbjahr
war also bis gestern dass diese
schokolade jetzt aber schlecht ist ich
würde eine million euro dagegen wetten
ich kenne auch jemand der hat bei redl
gearbeitet und er hat mir auch erzählt
wie viel da immer weggeworfen wird und
diese schokolade wer jetzt zb der müll
gelandet in vielen supermärkten oder man
hätte wieder zumindest an die tafel
gespendet aber es werden garantiert
nicht alle sachen an die tafel gespendet
und da landet so viel zurück
das glaubt man gar nicht jedes achte
lebensmittel dass wir kaufen landet im
müll statistisch gesehen das habe ich
mal gegoogelt so leute wenn man jetzt
öffnet sieht die schon ein bisschen
komisch aus aber das ist ganz normal das
ist nur die füllung heraus wir brechen
einfach mal ein stück ab das ist die
schokolade und sie schmeckt wie schon
erwartet ganz normal wenn ihr euch frage
höre ich die ganzen sachen habe einige
sachen habe ich damals in st
so ein überraschungspaket bestellt
deswegen hatte ich die noch da sind noch
mehr als nichtigkeiten dritte sind
allerdings alle noch haltbar also die
sind noch nicht mindestens abgelaufenen
ich halt drauf steht diese cola und den
käse habe ich vom rede bekommen die cola
behalten bis zum zweiten 2018 und damit
ich jetzt wenigstens immer was zu
trinken habe probieren war die man als
nächstes die müsste alte wirklich schon
im monat abgelaufen sein bzw 1 halben
monat gehe ich aber auch nicht von aus
[Musik]
schmeckt wirklich komplett gleich jede
andere oder gar keinen unterschied bei
der schokolade man jetzt sagen können
okay da merkt man dass sie schon mal
geschmolzen ist und dann wieder hart
geworden ist weil so aber ja
nicola absolut top ich habe am anfang
gesagt diese schokolade ist schon fast
ein jahr abgelaufen das merkt man auch
wenn man die anfangs ich würde sagen sie
zu gehen wir mal relativ zyklus wir
haben jetzt juli welche wo man eventuell
sehen kann dass sie nicht mehr ganz
frisch aussehen wenn ihr euch das
beantworte ich weiß dass nicht wieder
der kamera zu sehen
die waren halt war bis zum januar 2018
sind eigentlich schon seit zwei monaten
abgelaufen
wir machen die einfach mal aus ist halt
lakritz riecht schon kritisch das stimmt
vor allem wenn man dann das hier sieht
dass das hier oben leicht braun ist und
die schon zusammen kleben
ich glaube das sollte eigentlich nicht
so sein wie wäre ich mir jetzt selber
unsicher ob man ihn auch essen sollte
die ganze packung werde ich jetzt sicher
nicht essen aber ich würde sagen wir
probieren es einfach mal
[Musik]
ok rücken runter also hierbei muss sich
jetzt selber einsehen das sollte man
besser nicht mehr essen schmeckt komisch
schmeckt vor allem total bröselig dass
lakritze schmeckt auch nicht wirklich
nach einer krebs obwohl ich möchte jetzt
eigentlich mal
ich würde sagen machen wollten mit
diesem joghurt der haltbar war bis zum
zehnten dritten 2018 weil sie jetzt
eigentlich seit fünf tagen abgelaufen
bei joghurts kann ich sagen die halten
sich als ich habe noch nie jugend
gegessen der vielleicht schon monat
abgelaufen war dann aber nicht mehr nach
einem normalen job und geschmeckt hat
wenn man den kühlschrank lagert sind
hier auf jeden fall noch viel länger ist
für mich irgendwie wird voll wie so ein
auto so leute freundin mit der sahne die
wahrscheinlich gar keine richtige sagen
ist hat 19 cent gekostet das teil
schmeckt und auch das war nur hier
können sie noch mal wieder für die die
sich jetzt fragen ja nichts warum machst
du das eigentlich was soll das bringen
guck mal leute wenn dieses video jetzt
150000 menschen schauen mit der zeit und
so vielleicht ja auch mehr keine ahnung
und darf von 150.000 sagen okay das ist
nichts was wir nicht was wegschmeißen
probiere ich vorher mal habe ich
bestimmt durch dieses eine video
erreicht dass hunderttausend
lebensmittel nicht weggeschmissen werden
und hunderttausende lebensmittel ist
eine ganze menge also ist ein bestimmt
einige ton sowie machen einfach mal
weiter mit der milch da bin ich jetzt
selber mal gespannt und bericht aber
eigentlich noch gut
leute die mich sieht auf jeden fall ganz
natürlich aus das stimmt nicht irgendwas
drin oder so wenn irgendwas in der milch
drin schwimmt besser nicht trinken
übrigens feiern will ich eigentlich gar
nicht so aber kommt schmeckt absolut ich
ganz normal so eindeutig das haben wir
hier den wbl
da bin ich mal gespannt der liegt
ungefähr schon drei monate einfach so in
unserem kühlschrank rum ist auch
irgendwie so ein bisschen alter die
verpackung fühlt sich so ein bisschen
weich an guckt mal leute eigentlich kann
man da ganz normal rausnehmen es geht
hier jetzt nicht mehr so einfach da ist
irgendwie total weich und schmeckt total
intensiven nach käse milch schmeckt
jetzt nicht gut aber es schmeckt auch
nicht abgelaufen also man kann ihnen
garantiert essen möchte jetzt auch
verstehen dass ich nicht alles sofort
auf anhieb auf messen kann
danach schlecht ich habe am mittag
gegessen wir haben jetzt noch die
schokolade zum schluss jetzt wirklich
schon so einen live bilder abgelaufen
machen wir einfach mal auch so ja das
ist die milka edition cola schmeckt mir
eigentlich echt gut wenn man das jetzt
sieht sieht eigentlich auch noch
ziemlich gutes jahr diese himbeeren oder
was das sind ein bisschen zerbröckelt
auch ihrem band die die nicht mehr ganz
neu aus aber man muss auch hier sagen
schmeckt wie jede andere schokolade auch
wie bei der anschaffung lade man merkt
dass sie nicht wirklich lange im
kühlschrank lag die schokolade sagt die
ganze zeit da und in unserem fach drin
also die war nicht mal gekühlt hat sich
trotzdem noch gehalten ja leute ihr
könnt eure meinung dazu in die
kommentare schreiben was glaubt ihr wie
viele lebensmittel hat ihrem leben schon
weggeschmissen und das meiste was weg
oder probiert jetzt wenigstens vorher
noch schreibt es mir gerne in die
kommentare hier vieles durch
interessiert mich und jackson instagram
ab wir sehen uns dann eventuell mich
vorschlug wir sind uns eventuell schon
morgen wieder so ein samstag ich wünsche
euch noch einen schönen tag und ich
hoffe ihr habt jetzt eine andere
sichtweise auf das ganze schmeißen alles
sofort zeigt wo das wir hier in
deutschland so weit genug zu essen haben
und immer das essen können worauf wir
lust haben ausser die eltern sagen nein
heute gibt keine pommes kia hat rein